a Copenhagen on one hand it provided
some signals such as the numerous number
of important countries in the world
agreed that we should limit the
temperature increase globally about 2
degrees this was a positive outcome but
as a person who works an energy sector I
was disappointed that there was not a
clear signal coming from Copenhagen in
order to transform the energy sector
energy sector is responsible more than
two-thirds of the emissions which lead
to a climate change so if if if we want
to find the solution to climate change
this should go through transforming the
energy sector and in order to transform
the energy sector we needed a strong
clear signal from Copenhagen and for me
this has been that there was a global
agreement legally binding global
agreement for major countries of the
world to limit their emissions in the
year 2020 and this would have given a
strong signal to energy sector to make
investments on a much more sustainable
manner rather than a business as usual
manner I think this is an opportunity
which is missed but we can still make it
up if we have an agreement in Cancun in
Mexico this year
I think
we should be realistic today we are
coming to the end of februari 2010 we do
not have the momentum for a
transformation in the energy sector to
healthy things much more sustainable
that we had before Copenhagen the
momentum is unfortunate not as strong as
before Copenhagen it because of several
reasons from the failure of the
Copenhagen this partial failure of
Copenhagen meeting and perhaps some of
the stronger feelings about the
skepticism whether or there's a climate
change but I think ad realities of life
live at them namely the climate change
is effect and everybody who believes
that we have to fight against climate
change it needs to do something and to
as internal energy agency we think
climate changes one of the two major
strategic problems that we are facing
today second one is energy security and
when we look at the future we think that
most of the measures we have to take in
order to fight against climate change
helps to address the energy security as
well such as more renewable energy more
efficiency more advanced technologies
and more nuclear power so V is the
international energy agency the leading
energy organization in the world we will
be still pushing the button that the
sustainability efforts are going up will
be strong and we hope to push all the
buttons in order to have a successful
outcome in Cancun at this year